welcome back to Las Vegas now it's time
to get cooking with Seth nanny Bubbe
last time she showed us how to make
homemade pasta from scratch and this
time we're using that to make midnight
pasta let's check it out
hi everyone welcome back to nanny
bubbies kitchen on this Friday as always
we give gratitude to Chapman automotive
for always sponsoring our segments and
Melissa's produce for providing all of
our produce for all of our segments so
when last we saw you we were showing you
how to make homemade pasta and just how
easy it is the major question was do we
need to dry it or can we cook it fresh
and of course you can always cook it
fresh right after you make it and if
you're making this with children the
great thing is is you can go from
actually mixing kneading making the
pasta and right into the pot so let's
show you some tricks to getting it into
the pot the very right way so we filled
a stockpot nearly full about four or
five quarts with water put a little bit
of olive oil into the pot and we have
brought it to a very rapid boil now
here's the question I always get more
than any other question is how much salt
do we put in the water here is the
answer to that age-old question you want
to put enough salt in the water that it
begins to taste like you are in the
medical
see it's it's supposed to taste like
ocean water sea water so from that I
just pile it in to three but that's
about a tablespoon and a half so while
the pasta is cooking its four or five
minutes I'm going to show you how quick
and easy it is to make what is called
midnight pasta but before I do and while
the oil is heating up a little bit let
me tell you how midnight pasta got its
name
the folklore story is is that this pasta
is so easy to make and so quick that
when chefs all over the world got off
work and they got home and they were
tired they would make this pasta for
themselves because it's so easy so as
this is heating up let me tell you that
we start with a lot of garlic
so the original midnight the midnight
pasta recipe starts with about nine to
eleven cloves of garlic but this is my
thought if you're eating pasta at 11
o'clock or 12 o'clock at night you don't
want a lot of garlic so this is how we
peel it really fast and remember I
always recommend using a very different
cutting board for your garlic than you
do for your everything else because the
the smell and the taste will stick in
your board so as you can see I minced
this garlic instead of actually slicing
it so we're going to add this garlic
right into the pot
now you're gonna want to cook it for
about two minutes you don't want it to
brown you just want it to cook so after
the garlic is cooked really nicely and
gets good and soft we're gonna add a
half a cup of chopped parsley which has
just an amazing smell we're going to add
about half of a teaspoon of red chili
pepper flakes of course more if you like
more less if you like less let me tell
you the key to all great sauces for
pasta it's adding some of the pasta
water back into the bowl so we have
reserved about a cup and a half of the
cooked pasta water the salty pasta water
and it goes right into this sauce we're
going to bring it up to a higher
temperature bring it up to a boil and so
now as it begins to heat up we are going
to add our pasta which we have drained
garlic smells so good
all the parsley is getting into the
pasta what we want to do is add another
half cup of the cheese just to thicken
it up and again cooking is intuitive and
instinctual so if you feel that it's
just a little too juicy which I just did
you're gonna add just a little bit more
cheese back into it and
we're just gonna sprinkle this with a
little bit of Parmesan cheese maybe put
a sprig of parsley right in the middle
and serve it right out of the same pot
that you cooked it in that's it
midnight pasta made with the fresh pasta
that we made just two weeks ago of
course it didn't hang out for two weeks
we cooked it right afterwards and we're
cooking and enjoying and hoping that you
are to enjoy your weekend everybody I
will have to try that thank you
Stephanie Buffy check out chef Andi
Bubbe on Facebook and Instagram and
thanks to Chapman automotive for
sponsoring that segment we'll be right
back